una medida para eludir el juicio
político el presidente de Ecuador
Guillermo lasso anunció este miércoles
la disolución de la asamblea nacional
He decidido aplicar el artículo
148 de la Constitución de la república
que me otorga la Facultad de disolver la
asamblea nacional por grave crisis
política y conmoción interna el decreto
conocido como muerte Cruzada también
supone un adelanto de los comicios y
legislativos y presidenciales un anuncio
hecho menos de 24 horas después del
inicio del proceso para su censura en
una asamblea de mayoría opositora para
los demócratas tras la disolución del
legislativo lazo gobernará por decreto
Hasta que asuma el próximo gobierno en
su alocución acusó al parlamento de
trabajar en contra de los intereses del
Estado aprovechando la coyuntura el
expresidente Rafael Correa vio una
oportunidad para su fuerza política lo
que lazo hace es ilegal obviamente no
hay ninguna conmoción interna tan solo
no pudo comprar suficientes asambleístas
para salvarse En todo caso es la gran
oportunidad para liberarnos del lazo de
su gobierno y de sus asambleístas de
alquiler y recuperar la patria en la
víspera lazo había comparecido ante los
diputados como parte de su defensa se le
señalaba del presunto delito de
malversación por la firma de un contrato
con una empresa internacional la
contraloría general Consideró que el
acuerdo generó un perjurio para el
estado